fatima diallo and her family fled the
village of 2
after a night attack by gunmen although
the family was lucky to make it to a
gadugu alive
many other villages did not
the mother of four says she fled without
identity documents
and without them won't get a say in the
elections
i don't have a birth certificate and
don't know how to get one i need that to
get a new national identity card
which will allow me to receive my voter
card i won't be able to vote on sunday
because there's nothing that proves i'm
from burkina faso
she's one of hundreds of thousands of
broken abuse who have lost voting rights
because of the violence
sweeping across the west african nation
attacks by armed groups in 2015 marked
the beginning of a violent campaign by
al-qaeda
isil and the affiliates that have so far
killed thousands
and displaced more than a million people
in burkina faso activists say about 1
600 communities have been uprooted
because of the attacks against civilians
and burkina faso security forces
it's a difficult situation it's
complicated and it's the first time in
our history this many people
will be disenfranchised but it's the
reality
not because they don't want to vote but
simply because they can't
officials say more than 400 000 new
voters couldn't be added to the register
this year
because of the violence and widespread
displacement
the elections commission has already
given up on conducting the polls in
hundreds of villages
across the country
back at the shelter for the dialogues
fatumata has only one wish
that whoever becomes president after
sunday's vote will end the violence so
that they can go back
to rebuild their lives not an impossible
dream
but like millions of other victims of
the violence sweeping the sahel region
of west africa
the family may have to wait a bit longer
to see this dream
come true ahmed iris al jazeera